[Music]
foreign
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
i'm gonna get straight into inshallah
uh majid nawaz has been attacked
uh in soho so this was tweeted tonight i
was racially attacked while alone
outside soho theater from behind as i
bent down to pick up my phone
the white male assailant called me a
effin packy
as he hit me in the face with maybe a
signet ring
and ran away like a coward he look he
took nothing he was just
a racist so basically another thing that
he said this is this is so this was
after his treatment etc went on uh he
said that i just returned home from the
hospital after having my wound glued up
i owe a huge debt to the two lovely
young witnesses
both white non-muslims male and female
who called the police
and waited with me to console me and
then provided a witness statement
i won't i didn't identify them as that i
don't wish to endanger them
your kindness kept me sane i also thank
soho theater for identifying the racist
assailant
on their cctv footage i found the police
first responders
all of whom were white non-muslims i
don't know why he keeps repeating that
for their professionalism even though
after the kind policeman asked my
profession
he did ask what's lbc i thanked
stephanie powell
also a white non-muslim that's the first
time manager of
hawks more seven dials who was kind
enough to
re-bandage my head personally in a
restaurant after it became apparent that
my wound was still bleeding
i thank our doctors and nurses all
non-muslims fourth time
who treated me with diligence and care
now
let's get something straight okay
firstly i want to make a disclaimer okay
we are against any kind of acts of
violence
period but we just want to go a bit
further here now
i don't want to come here and just you
know yeah you know we just you know
condemn etc hold on a second
let's let's let's give a bigger picture
yeah we need to not look at the pixel
but we have to look at the picture yeah
then we can maybe understand the pixel
now brothers and sisters this makes it
very simple yeah
magic noise is somebody who has tweeted
stuff like this and he is
constantly constantly
says the same nonsense this is one of
those we pakistani muslim men
all know what is believed and taught
among conservative members of our
community
about western women islamists will deny
this
in the seat leftist will reject this in
shock populists will use this to hate
liberals must address this in haste he
even does poetry
masha allah um as
an asian man himself a non-muslim asian
man you know he's got
racist racially got attacked um
i want to make something clear yeah
because this is there's a big irony here
yeah the guy who attacked him
if he knew that magic nawaz his buddies
with tommy robinson
and supports yanni the far right to be
honest
maybe not directly indirectly he may
have not even carried that attack out
but then again the reason why this man
carried out this attack is because most
likely and maybe
he has been listening to lbc and when
you listen to the radio you do not see
the person
you're listening to you only hear the
person
so therefore he must have been listening
to majid noah's
pathetic excuses and reasons
why he attacks and makes grooming gang a
pakistani men issue
and always constantly attacks muslims
claiming to be a muslim even though we
know very clearly that he is not a
muslim in no way shape or form
he is constantly pushing this um
speech forward he's always talking about
this now what's
really funny is the following yeah when
his post what i
read to you when he talks about
non-muslim ladies
non-muslim police officers non-muslim
this none wasn't that he's basically
trying to say
maybe maybe that's what i'm getting from
that message not all non-muslims are the
same
this was just one non-muslim that came
and did this attack even though we know
many
attacks have been happened uh happening
uh because of the far right yeah okay
and racist people yeah
now look at irony he's claiming that
look you know don't judge them all
but you are the same person who goes
and vilifies asian men to be these
groomers who are there out to hunt
and attack islam yes you claim to be a
muslim
but you attack islam more than probably
tommy robinson
and then you get surprised when you're
grooming yes you're actually grooming
these men who was most likely if this
man got caught i would love to ask him a
question
did you listen to lbc a man called
imagination yeah you know
that's one of the reasons why i built my
hate well guess what me the man you
attacked is imagine there was
you know this is your teacher you are
grooming these people
to build hate build hate and this is
what exactly tommy robinson does and
this is what
isis does they build hate and their foot
soldiers carry out their attacks
this is what happens and now you're
surprised you're upset
why did this man come and pick on an
asian man
that looks like a muslim and decided to
attack you you're surprised you should
not be surprised
you are breeding these people these
people
are a by-product of you and the likes of
you
so don't come here asking for sympathy i
have
no sympathy i'm sorry and you are the
very same man
when i called lbc and i asked you the
atrocities that the israeli
government the zionists not the jews
we have a lot of jewish friends that
come to the park where stanford hill
there's a lot of jewish community
i know some people there we're not
talking about the jews we're talking
about
zionists yes these people that you
support
and when i rang you and i asked you to
condemn
israel for the atrocities of shooting
little boys
throwing stones shooting them with a
sniper rifle
and killing them you said no no n-o
israel is not a terrorist state is that
an answer for okay he's really told to
shoot
innocent little kids in the head for
throwing stones so i just wanted to
ask you because the way you defend
israel to me it seems like you get paid
really well by it
he did not criticize israel once i came
nothing
i'm telling him about israel people kids
being shot in their head
and he's telling me oh let's talk about
the stoning the rights of palestinians
even their children are wholesale denied
and it's appalling
have i answered your question a decade
ago where he's staunchly against he was
actually
exactly saying what i was saying
apartheid state on israel what what was
it
that made this u-turn with him
is it ali is it that jews are paying me
is that what you're saying
oh oh by the way you're defending them i
would not be surprised you could get in
good amounts
yeah good amounts from jews yeah yeah no
israel i didn't see
that no and now you're here today
if you're looking for sympathy you have
zero sympathy from me
and a lot of muslims will agree with me
you need to stop your hate because if
you don't you're going to breed it
further
and it happened to be this racist man
who's probably an islamophobe
who wanted to carry out an attack and
attack an asian person
it happened to be you if it wasn't you
know that it was going to be another
asian man
another muslim man whoever it maybe it
might be in a sister
it might be in a muslim sister so
very simply and to the point is that if
you do not carry on
if you if you carry on with this
approach
then do not be surprised if the chickens
come home
to roost and like i said before on his
post about non-muslim nominees and
non-muslims i was talking about
then do not generalize and make it seem
like all of the asian people i'm not
asian yeah so i'm not here you can't say
i'm defend i'm not asian myself
okay but to generalize and build hate
this is what's going to happen and
you've clearly said not every non-muslim
is the same
there are some non-muslims a lot of not
some excuse me there's a lot of
non-muslims i know personally who are
lovely people
who are nice people very very nice
people
and that's how it is the same goes with
a lot of people it's a minority
like the far right far-right extremism
you have
some islamic extremists like isis yeah
and these people live off each other
their business partners yeah one carries
attack he says look what they've done to
us let's carry an attack and then you go
look
this is what they've done to us and it's
going to carry on this is going to be an
endless cycle
i hope you learn a lesson and you've
actually
lived it for yourself what every single
one of us go through on a daily basis of
thinking
okay who's going to attack us today
sisters are feared are scared to go out
on the streets
because of why because of your nonsense
your
rubbish yeah that you're promoting and
spewing out there
and then your foot soldiers yeah who you
know score her own goal
by attacking their own teacher yeah
that's what's going to happen if you
don't stop
so hopefully this has taught you a
lesson
and you will stop this and hopefully
people can
live in peace and they do not get
brainwashed
that was about brothers and sisters it
was just a reaction video want to make
this very simple and clear
i have no sympathy for this guy somebody
who supports
israel and the atrocities against the
palestinians yeah
who did not condemn them condemn them
once when i said
are they not a terrorist state shooting
innocent people
you have zero sympathy from me zero
until next time assalamu alaykum do give
me your comments
uh in the section below inshaallah and
maya bless you guys till next time and
please please please
do share this with imagine us